2021 was not a fresh start.
A sampling of newspapers’ front pages, a
stroll through single-digit cable channels,
a scroll through your trusted news sites all
advance the same sentiment: a new year doesn’t
mean a new world, a fresh fourth digit doesn’t
refresh the headlines.
Rather, 2021 was a year of news stories evolving,
of headlines maturing.
Pandemic stories went from panic and uncertainty
over the virus to panic and uncertainty over
the vaccine and its roll out; stories on paper-product
shortages turned into headlines outlining
outright supply chain chaos; coverage of police
violence, racial injustice, and subsequent
protests moved from the streets and into the
courtroom.
The strongest point of continuity from last
year to this year, however, was that a host
of stories burned so bright that they left
little oxygen for smaller ones to breathe.
So, we did it again, we assembled a list of
news stories, one for each country, that you
likely missed in 2021.
Some rules are the same from last year.
We’re not covering the big stories—you
won’t hear about America ending its longest
war, the traffic jam in the Suez Canal, and
you certainly won’t hear me utter the all-consuming
C-word.
In its absence, you’ll notice that two other
c-words came to dominate our headlines: climate
change, and coup d'etats.
These themes point to the change in this year’s
video—rather than focusing on finding stories
distant from the C-word, this edition’s
headlines reflect the experience of each country’s
general populace—stories that often revolve
around responses to a rapidly changing world
and unnervingly unstable governments.
The stories aren’t all dark though–2021
was tough, but it was also one filled with
the heartening and, of course, the quirky.
Not only does this people-first focus inform
the stories we chose, but also how we organized
the stories themselves.
Rather than going from most populous to least
like last year, we’re using the Human Development
Index or HDI.
HDI is a metric aimed to quantify standard
of living, ranking each country between 0
and 1 based on three dimensions: a long and
happy life, accumulation of education, and
earnings.
The United Nations compiles this list using
an algorithm that includes indicators such
as life expectancy at birth, gross national
income per capita, and mean years of schooling
for adults 25 and over.
HDI was created to, as the UN states, “emphasize
that people and their capabilities should
be the ultimate criteria for assessing the
development of a country, not economic growth
alone.”
Put simply, HDI is the best metric available
to frame this trip around the globe from the
perspective of everyday people.
But not all of the 196 UN-recognized countries
and territories we cover have an HDI score.
Missing statistics in per capita income, life
expectancy, or years of education means that
seven countries didn’t have a score, but
they did make news, so we’ll start there,
and then go from lowest HDI to highest.
We’ve spent a lot of time explaining, but
you’re here for the headlines.
So let’s get started with the first 98.
We start this year in the country that the
HDI calculators probably know the least about:
North Korea.
The Hermit Kingdom countered its natural disposition
when it decided to reopen lines of communication
with South Korea via the hotline that directly
connects Seoul and Pyongyang.
The hotline’s existed in one form or another
since the 1970s but has been severed twice
in the past two years on account of the failed
Trump summit with the north, and joint military
exercises between the US and the south.
From nations we’d like to know more about
to continents that spark curiosity, Venturi,
an innovative auto company and Formula E team
from Monaco, announced its plan to launch
its electric polar exploration vehicle in
Antarctica.
While the world’s been sending vehicles
down there for decades, Venturi’s will be
the first that spews zero emissions as it
transports scientists across the continent
to conduct important climate-related research.
While it’s been tested on French ski resorts,
the sole focus has been getting the vehicle
ready for the southern continent–a mission
laid bare by the vehicle’s name, “Antarctica.”
The news out of Nauru suggested that 2021
wasn’t one to critically rethink its international
agreements but a chance to double down.
At least that was the case when the country
renewed its deal with Australia to serve as
an offshore processing location for asylum
seekers looking to enter the popular migration
destination.
While the extension keeps the island nation
in the good graces of regional power broker
Australia, it keeps the island connected to
and complicit in an asylum system that many,
including the UN, have decried as cruel and
inhuman with its delays, decrepit living conditions,
and reports of abuse.
2021 was an Olympics year, and one of the
smallest countries in the world took two podiums:
San Marino, a 23-square mile, 60-square kilometer
enclave surrounded by Italy, earned its first
Olympic medal.
Women’s trap shooter Alessandra Perilli
took home a bronze during the summer games.
But it wasn’t just her award—now the country,
with 33,000 people, came in first for being
the least populated territory in the world
to earn an Olympic medal, surpassing Bermuda’s
70,000.
Somalia got its first taste of the silver
screen in 30 years, when the National Theatre
of Somalia reopened for a screening featuring
two short films by a homegrown director.
The theater closed in 1991 at the start of
the country’s civil war, has been used frequently
by warlords as their headquarters, and was
then bombed by anti-entertainment jihadists.
Its reopening, though tenuous and under heavy
security, marked a flicker of hope for civilians—especially
the flick-loving ones.
And we’re not even into the list but we’re
already at climate change.
Tuvalu’s foreign minister went viral for
addressing the COP26 climate summit knee-deep
in water–a strong image that demonstrates
the peril facing the island nation which only
rises to 15 feet, or 4.5 meters, above sea
level.
He’s asking that if the nation goes underwater,
it can retain ownership to its maritime zones
and rights as a state even if residents have
to relocate–existential questions for a
very non-existential crisis.
In a less systemic and more personal response
to climbing temperatures, The Vatican’s
most famous resident donated 15,000 ice-creams
to local prisoners during an unpleasant hot
snap in a summer that set heat records across
the Italian peninsula.
While the gesture was admittedly minor, it
signaled the Vatican’s dedication to aid
the local population down on its luck.
The Vatican’s charity office has also provided
free testing and vaccines during the pandemic
and has taken locals experiencing homelessness
out for pizza.
In what's been a tough year for a myriad of
reasons, Niger made history with its first-ever
peaceful, democratic transition of power.
Once President Mahamadou Issoufou relinquished
the position after two terms—the limit outlined
in the country's constitution—Niger elected
and placed it's new President, Mohamed Bazoum.
While claims of fraud, protest, outright violence,
and a stymied coup nearly derailed it, 2021’s
successful transition of power was the country's
first since it gained independence in 1960.
Just as Niger elected its new leader, the
Central African Republic lost one of their
own… which the world found out about over
social media.
Heavily criticized for the government’s
inability to foster peace among ethnic groups,
it’s worrying ties with Russia, and its
bungled relationship with France who have
now pulled their military aid out of the country,
Firmin Ngrebada announced that he and his
government had handed over their resignation
on Twitter.
Just North, in Chad, 2021 saw both the suspension
and reinstatement of the Chadian Football
Association by the hands of FIFA.
Citing government interference in Chad’s
effort to seize the Association’s authority
and training grounds, an unsurprising overstep
under the ruling military council, soccer’s
ruling body banned the country from international
tournaments.
While restrictions were ultimately lifted,
Chad was disqualified from the all-important
2021 Africa Cup of Nations.
The world’s youngest country, South Sudan,
rang in its 10th anniversary with a first,
as the mobile provider, Digitel, launched
in the capital city of Juba.
Digitel is the first South Sudanese-owned
and operated mobile network and its stated
goal is to roll out 4G in Juba at competitive
rates and provide mobile service for remote
areas—a meaningful step in the country’s
development.
Important infrastructure developments might
be afoot in nearby Burundi as well.
In July, the heads of state from Burundi and
the Democratic Republic of the Congo signed
cooperative agreements aimed to foster trade,
stamp out rebels, and literally bridge the
Ruzizi River-sized gap between the neighboring
countries.
Expanding rail lines and electrification along
the borderlands are also key components of
the agreements.
These deals signal on paper, what it’s leaders
claim have always connected the two countries––in
their words, a historic “brotherhood.”
Nonuplets is the crossword-worthy term that
reached household-level parlance across Mali
in 2021.
Backed by nation-wide well-wishes, 25-year-old
Halima Cissé was sent to a specialist in
Morocco in late March to deliver seven babies––or
so she thought.
To her doctor’s surprise, Cissé harbored
nine, all of which were born in good health.
Cissé’s nonuplets now mark the record for
most babies born at once.
As the world warms, cities are getting hot––sometimes
deadly hot.
This is the case in Freetown, the capital
city of Sierra Leone.
In the face of deadly heat waves, the city
has appointed an extreme heat official to
draft a comprehensive heat strategy, raise
general awareness, and create ways to protect
the city’s most exposed.
Freetown’s extreme heat official is not
just the first in Africa, but only the third
such official in the world, joining those
recently appointed in Miami and Athens.
Inspiration takes many forms.
For Burkina Faso nationals, it took the form
of the massive, smiling “Iron Biby,” who
set a new world record in log lifting.
While Western media might have overlooked
his 504-pound-over-the-head-lift in Glasgow,
Scotland, his triumph was big news in Burkina
Faso, as residents welcomed him back at the
airport in droves.
The moment wasn’t lost on “Iron Biby,”
who dedicated his trophy to his home country
as “a message of hope.”
On the other side of Africa, in Mozambique,
researchers have found that elephants have
begun ditching their tusks in the name of
survival.
Once rare, tuskless African elephants have
become increasingly common over the last 50
years––largely, on account of poachers.
With 90% of the country’s elephants killed
for their ivory during Mozambique’s civil
war, tuskless elephants benefitted from an
increased opportunity to pass down their tuskless
genes.
With poaching down and conservation up in
recent decades, though, it’s expected that
tusks will come back in vogue.
If you’re looking for a reminder that the
past is very much part of the present, look
no further than Eritrea.
Over 300 Eritreans born during Italy’s rule
have demanded Italian citizenship.
In the seven-odd decades since colonial rule,
Eritrean claims to Italian citizenship based
on paternal bloodlines have fallen on deaf
ears.
Racial rules during the fascist period, current
Italian immigration policy, lack of documentation,
and limited mobility under Eritrea’s dictatorial
rule have kept an estimated thousands of Eritreans
from accessing Italian citizenship.
The latest push for recognition, though, shows
these claims aren’t fading quietly.
Elegant, meticulously groomed and arranged
trees and bushes aren’t likely what one
would expect along the war-torn streets of
Yemen.
But that’s what you’ll run into when passing
through the city of Marib, where trees sculpted
into shapes, figures, and animals line roadways.
In a region of critical strategic importance,
representing one of the government’s last
surviving strongholds, this city beautification
project, begun in 2016, has offered a welcome
respite from the country’s dragging civil
war.
“Dragging” also describes the legacy of
the West African Ebola outbreak, as the repercussions
of the epidemic that “ended” in 2016 may
still be taking shape.
Researchers suspect that this year’s Ebola
outbreak of 20-plus probable cases in Guinea
was triggered by a survivor of the earlier
outbreak.
While scientists knew that in the rarest of
cases the virus could shed and transmit up
to 500 days after infection, the finding that
a body harbored the virus for a full five
years was a surprising and frightening development.
Fifty thousand dollars still goes a long way.
In Liberia, $50,000, and doing the right thing
with it, will earn you a chance to meet the
president.
That was the case for Emmanuel Tuloe, a teenage
motorcycle taxi driver, who found a plastic
bag on the side of the road stuffed with fifty
grand in cash and returned it in full to the
businesswoman who had lost it.
His good deed was praised by Liberians and
earned him the chance to meet the president,
with whom he wanted to discuss getting himself
and fellow youngsters back in school.
For the first time, male green sea turtles
off the coast of Guinea-Bissau are getting
GPS tags to better understand the endangered
species’ travel and feeding patterns.
Not only is the attention a boon for the in-trouble
turtles, it signals the growing trust between
outside researchers and notoriously protective
island residents who have successfully defended
and worshipped this sacred environment for
centuries.
Researchers have tread lightly and, in turn,
benefitted mightily from shared local knowledge
and expertise to catch and tag the ranging
reptiles.
Finding a middle-ground built on trust and
respect has also shaped an important development
in the Democratic Republic of the Congo as
calls for the repatriation of artifacts by
activists and officials made headway in 2021.
In the wake of the global Black Lives Matter
movement, the Belgian government released
their plan to return all illegitimately procured
African artifacts, most of which were stolen
from the Congo.
This plan marks the first systematic, government-led
effort to return objects stolen during the
country’s violent colonization on the continent.
Across several Malawian cities, protesters
took to the street bonded by the same plight—data
prices are too darn high.
It seems a fair frustration, as one gigabyte
costs nearly $28, making it the third-most
expensive rate of all UN-recognized countries.
Malawi regulators have expressed their concern
over exorbitant rates as the prices threaten
to slow social-economic development.
The stories of two prominent headline-makers
collided this year when Tedros Adhanom, director-general
of the World Health Organization, spoke on
the dire situation in north Ethiopia.
In November, the director-general said that
the Tigray region of Ethiopia was under a
“systematic blockade” and that people
were dying because of the lack of supplies.
He also noted that Tigrayans were being arrested
en masse.
From Tigray himself, Adhanom never directly
assigned blame as he’s worked diligently
to maintain a neutral position on the civil
war that has consumed his home country.
As part of their seemingly odd and certainly
confusing court case against Myanmar, The
Gambia won an important ruling this year.
On behalf of the Rohingya, a Muslim ethnic
group persecuted in Myanmar, the tiny Gambia,
with the backing of the Organization of Islamic
Cooperation, a group of 57 nation-states,
filed a lawsuit against Myanmar in 2019.
In September of this year, a judge ordered
Facebook to disclose account records pertaining
to the persecution in Myanmar––a big win
for The Gambia, as it’s widely understood
that social media played a key role in the
2017 genocide.
Sudan’s progress toward democratic rule
hit a major speed bump this October when the
military seized power.
Since the ousting of Omar al-Bashir in 2019,
Sudan had been trending in the democratic
direction––that was, until this most recent
coup.
In response to the backslide, thousands of
protestors hit the streets in Khartoum, while
the US suspended a $700 million aid package
meant to aid in the transition towards civilian
governance.
The story is still developing though, as the
US and UN are pressuring the military to release
imprisoned politicians and return a civilian-government
to power.
Democracy is in trouble in Haiti, too.
After a deadly earthquake, a presidential
assasination, and bout after bout of gang
violence, chaos and uncertainty are primed
to carry into 2022 as general elections have
been postponed for the fourth time.
This postponement comes after the prime minister
decided to dissolve the council responsible
for organizing elections.
The PM has said he plans on naming a new council,
but has not committed to a timeline––a
move that leaves the spiraling state, well,
spiraling.
One hundred and thirty young female footballers
and their families from Afghanistan can finally
take a deep breath.
Four months after fleeing Kabul as the Taliban
closed in, and after stops in Portugal and
Pakistan, the Afghan athletes arrived in London
via chartered flight.
Their escape was made possible by a litany
of NGOs and philanthropists, one of which
was the chairman of Leeds United––the
club where the girls will join the youth team
ranks.
2021 was a big year for African astronomy––especially
for the Senegalese scientist Maram Kaire,
as the International Astronomical Union retitled
the less-than-personable asteroid 35462 to
“MaramKaire,” no spaces.
Not only making the asteroid hurtling between
Mars and Jupiter more approachable, the renaming
serves as a recognition of the life’s work
of the director of Africaspace and founding
member of the African Astronomical Society,
while also shining a light on the nation’s
science ambitions.
Senegal doesn’t hold a monopoly on Western
African ambition, though.
Bureaucrats in Togo took the difficult task
of distributing pandemic-related relief funds
head on this year by developing a remarkably
efficient digital payout platform.
With only spotty census data and flawed tax
records, officials creatively leveraged voter
registration to verify applicants before paying
out the aid over SMS––a program that makes
the US’s look antiquated by comparison.
The violence that’s gripped Ethiopia for
the past year has done no favors for East
African neighbors either––see the tiny
coastal nation of Djibouti.
In July, protestors responding to a state-led
attack blocked the rail line that connects
the landlocked Ethiopia to the ocean.
Djibouti’s port, through which a whopping
90% of all Ethiopian goods pass, is the country’s
key economic driver, and while the rail line’s
closure wasn’t permanent, instability in
Ethiopia has hampered the reliant Djibouti
economy to the tune of an estimated $1.7 billion
dollars in lost commerce.
It’s been a tough few years for the ski
industry—and Lesotho’s Afriski Mountain
Resort proved that while unique in terms of
its status as one of the two resorts in southern
Africa, it wasn’t an exception to the struggles.
Rather than go under when South African border
closures led to a 90% drop in visitors, the
resort adapted, this year offering incentives
and reduced rates to get locals on the hill—some,
for the very first time—while also finding
creative renovation projects to keep its local
staff employed.
Chameleons, by their very nature, are hard
to spot.
A chameleon measuring just 29 millimeters
from tip to tail—nearly impossible.
And yet, a group of scientists in northern
Madagascar discovered a pair of these nano-chameleons
who are now in the record books as the smallest
of the planet’s 11,500 reptiles.
Like so much in Madagascar, though, the future
of the little lizard is up in the air as habitat
loss has conservationists scrambling to protect
the new finding.
From new findings, to expensive and rare findings,
Petra Diamonds, the British producer of pink
diamonds donned by the Queen herself, has
settled to pay 4.3 million pounds to 71 Tanzanian
claimants who’ve accused the mining company
of, among other things, beating, stabbing,
and detaining them during their time as miners.
While the settlement makes “no admission
of liability,” Petra has vowed to fund community
projects and prevent future incidents.
In the Ivory Coast, stamping out illegal cocoa
grow operations has proved next to impossible.
But that could change with the adoption of
the most recent European Commission plan to
curb global deforestation.
If implemented, this plan would require companies
importing cocoa products into the EU to provide
GPS data on the product's origin to ensure
it wasn’t illegally harvested.
For the Ivory Coast, spreading the responsibility
of halting illegal cocoa production will help
protect the meager 15% of its biodiverse forest
still standing.
It’s been 15 years since Shell’s Nigerian
subsidiary’s pipelines poisoned the farmlands
of the villages of Goi and Oruma, and 13 years
since the case went to court.
But this year, a Dutch court finally ruled
that Royal Dutch Shell and its Nigerian subsidiary
must compensate the villages for a still undecided
amount and install warning systems along its
pipelines to curb the next disaster.
In Rwanda, the crackdown on dissidents under
President Paul Kagame’s government has extended
to YouTube creators.
Dieudonne Niyonsenga, whose channel, Ishema
TV covers topics such as human rights abuses
and has over 15 million views, was sentenced
to seven years in prison after being found
guilty of forgery, humiliation of state officials,
and two other charges.
He was the second Rwandan YouTube critic to
be arrested in a country where freedom of
expression is becoming increasingly costly.
Expressing dissent with Uganda’s 900 mile,
1,500 kilometer oil pipeline project is becoming
costly, too.
Citing lack of compensation for land and a
host of environmental dangers, local activists
and international NGOs are raising concerns
over the project that begins in Murchison
National Park and borders Lake Victoria.
It seems they’re fighting an uphill battle
against the project, which is backed by Tanzania,
Uganda, and companies from France and China,
as Uganda has arrested six protestors––a
move some see as a scare tactic.
Elsewhere on the continent, people’s voices
are getting through.
In Benin, a law passed that drastically expands
access to abortion and largely puts the decision
in women’s hands.
What used to be legal only in cases of life-threatening
pregnancies, rape, and incestuous relationships,
is now allowed on account of a wide range
of reasons within the first 12 weeks of pregnancy.
Globally, this move has been hailed by women’s
rights activists, and regionally, this makes
Benin the most progressive country on the
issue in West Africa.
In a country that’s 90% Sahara, with only
one permanent river, water’s hard to come
by.
Facing shortages and inconsistent supply,
Mauritania recently launched a fundraising
effort to secure $317 million for a project
that will provide water to half a million
in the south of the arid country.
Counting on several financiers from across
the Arab world, the project will pipe water
to urban and rural users in a bid to minimize
the gap between the two and help to realize
the region’s agricultural potential.
From a country with limited water, to one
with little land, it’s been a momentous
year for sports fans on the island of Comoros,
as the nation of under a million was ground
zero for a history-making run by the national
soccer team.
Minnows on the continental level, Comoros
held World Cup qualifiers Egypt to a draw
and went unbeaten during the African Cup League
of Nations qualifying stage—a Cinderella
run that will see the nation make the cup
tournament for the first time.
Not bad for a team that didn’t even exist
until 2006.
As teamseas-ers, we don’t condone tossing
trash into the ocean.
But sometimes such littering lends itself
to a story.
Picking up plastic along the beaches of a
Papua New Guinean Island, Steven Amos stumbled
across a message in a bottle that had traveled
1,500 miles, or 2,400 kilometers, after being
tossed overboard by an American sailor two
years prior.
In a nation struggling with major plastic
pollution, perhaps Amos smiled not only at
the friendly note, but also at the fact that
it was contained in a nice, reusable glass
bottle.
How young is too young to charge someone with
a crime?
Pakistan faced down this very question when
they charged an 8-year-old of blasphemy when
the Hindu child peed in an Islamic school
library.
In the incident’s wake, police charged the
boy while, in reaction to the perceived disrespect,
a mob vandalized a Hindu temple.
Eventually though, the state stepped in and
punished the cops who arrested the child,
dropped all charges, and organized payment
for the temple’s repairs.
Charges that are sticking, however, were laid
against two transgender women who were simply
having dinner in Cameroon when they were arrested
for alleged homosexuality.
Later, they were sentenced to five years in
jail, which some say is a death sentence in
the male-dominated prison system.
The arrests and high-profile nature of the
case—as one of the women is an activist
for trans rights—exemplifies the anti-LGBTQ
sentiments and laws that are still common
in African countries, with at least 30 of
them criminalizing homosexuality.
Technology seems to be a storyline, and this
is clearly the case for ISIS-affiliated women
held at the Al-Hawl refugee camp in Syria,
where they are marrying men they meet online
in order to receive income and the slim chance
of eventual repatriation.
The camp, which is home to nearly 60,000 women
and children, is teeming with squalor and
extremist ideas.
Yet, jihadist men reportedly see it as a badge
of honor to care for the women there through
these virtual marriages, even though they
rarely move beyond anything but digital.
For something much more tangible, a Solomon
Islands man digging in his backyard to install
a septic system struck something hard, but
this was the opposite of treasure.
Instead, he discovered more than 100 unexploded
World War II bombs, which came as a real surprise
and a tragic reminder of the devastation the
Pacific Islands suffered during that era,
when thousands of bombs were dropped and munitions
stores, like this one, were common.
The ordinances were successfully, and thankfully,
removed by a specialized team.
In the opposite of underground, Zimbabwe plans
to launch its first satellite, the ZIMSAT-1,
in February.
It will be used to help organizations and
officials collect data that relates to ground
cover and drought, as well as transmit signals
for amateur radio stations.
Zimbabwe’s space program has grown quickly
in just three years since being established,
and follows on the heels of other African
countries extending upward as well.
Though many countries focus on the pressing
humanitarian needs first, the continent’s
satellite fleet now stands at 44 as they increasingly
recognize the importance of strategic space
investment.
Break out those dancing shoes, because the
rumba may officially be a part of worldwide
intangible cultural heritage.
The Republic of the Congo and the Democratic
Republic of the Congo applied to UNESCO for
the official designation, which would protect
the dance’s history and cement its importance.
The rumba was born in 19th-century Cuba, combining
the drumming of enslaved Africans with the
melodies of Spanish colonizers.
But it’s not just of historical importance,
because the rumba has modern-day relevance
too, including the 1960’s “Independence
Cha Cha,” a version of the rumba that celebrated
the freedom of Belgian Congo.
In the same region, downstream effects from
an Angolan diamond mine were catastrophically
felt in a toxic spill that sickened more than
1 million people, killed 12, and decimated
fish and wildlife.
Waste from the largest diamond mine in Angola
leaked into the Kasai River, which eventually
reached the Congo river, where large amounts
of heavy metal were detected.
The mine, which is partially owned by a Russian
company, acknowledged there had been a leak,
but said that it was just sand and mud, and
of course, they claimed no responsibility
for the disaster.
There’s no accountability in this story
either, but there is a bit of good news from
a country that’s increasingly cracking down
on the freedom of the press: Myanmar released
American journalist Danny Fenster from prison
just days after he was sentenced to 11 years
for charges that included incitement of violence
and visa violations.
The military in Myanmar has clamped down on
the media since seizing power in February,
stripping publications of their licenses and
banning outlets from broadcasting.
Fenster, however, was the first foreign journalist
to be convicted for charges he says were without
warrant, and thanks to negotiations by a former
US ambassador to the UN, now he’ll go free.
Imprisonment in an authoritarian country is
one person’s nightmare, while 10 million
fruit bats descending on a condensed swamp
area might sound like another’s.
But for conservationists in Zambia, it’s
essential.
The bats are key to African ecology because
they eat fruits and berries and distribute
the seeds during their continental migration.
Now these environmentalists are fighting a
proposal for a 17,500-acre, or 7,000-hectare,
wheat, soy, and corn farm that would be built
on the national park’s borders and threaten
the bat’s habitat, and existence, altogether.
In another story about West African instability,
Guinea junta leader Mamady Doumbouya was sworn
in after a successful September coup, marking
the fourth coup in the region in the past
year.
Doumboya’s party overthrew former president
Alpha Conde for what they said was continued
corruption, but political upheaval continues
to mire the area, and now a regional economic
council has placed economic sanctions and
travel restrictions on the Guinean junta.
Sometimes governmental overreach isn’t always
so unpleasant, as is the case with a defanged
and declawed lion named Hima.
He was reunited with his owner after the Cambodian
prime minister got involved.
Initially, Hima was seized after TikTok videos
of him living casually in a high-end Phnom
Penh neighborhood—something the government
deemed inappropriate—went viral.
But additional posts showed a clear bond between
the two after their separation, and following
public calls for reunification, the prime
minister announced the two would be rejoined.
Speaking of lions, Kenya is known as a wildlife
wonderland, but just how many creatures crawl
there was an unknown number until the country
completed its first wildlife census this year.
Using planes, drones, helicopters, boats,
and 4x4s, researchers tallied the populations
of more than 30 species across nearly 60%
of the country to establish a baseline for
one of the world’s most unique ecological
places.
Using estimates from the past, the numbers
of elephants, some 36,280, seem to be going
up, but black rhinos, just 897, have fallen
to critically endangered levels.
Kenya counts wildlife, and Nepal counts how
many people reach the top of Mount Everest.
Now, they’re unhappy with three Indian climbers
who allegedly falsified their summit of the
world’s highest peak in 2016.
This year, the Nepalese government penalized
them by banning them for six years, essentially
preventing them from actually trying to get
to the top another time.
The Nepalese ministry verifies climbs through
photographic evidence, and while these three
had the photos, presumably photoshopped, they
reportedly didn’t have enough oxygen to
have feasibly completed the trip.
Back at sea level, impoverished East Timor
is at an interesting economic crossroads,
exploring eco-tourism, offshore drilling,
and now, carbon capture storage as a way to
boost the country’s revenue.
Australia has proposed capturing its own carbon
waste and paying to store it in East Timor’s
nearly depleted Bayu-Undan oil field, which
is expected to run out in the next couple
of years.
Proponents see this as a creative environmental
solution, and critics say it’s simply shifting
climate change responsibility from a rich
country to a poor one.
Nearby Vanuatu is a remote Pacific island
with just 300,000 residents.
So why did some 2,000 politicians, business
owners, and criminals get citizenship there
recently?
Because for $130,000, they can.
The citizenship-by-investment program is legal,
and gives these new residents visa-free access
to the UK and European Union.
But, some worry the increased interest in
this island—where the passport program accounted
for nearly 42% of government revenue in 2020—might
be fertile ground for money laundering and
international mischief.
In a move that signals the increasing geopolitical
importance of Africa, Twitter hired its first
employees on the continent in the country
of Ghana, where freedom of speech protections
and online freedoms made it an ideal location.
The social media company announced it would
fill 11 positions, with plans to officially
open an office there once pandemic restrictions
and work-from-home orders are relaxed.
For more than 35 years, Eswatini’s King
Mswati III has ruled as absolute monarch and
flaunted a lavish, luxurious lifestyle.
The problem?
Sixty percent of the country’s 1.1 million
residents live in poverty and they’re over
his opulence.
For months, residents have participated in
pro-democracy protests that have left scores
dead and many more wounded.
Neighboring African countries, including South
Africa, upon which Eswatini heavily relies,
are stepping in to help navigate the movement,
which many say won’t be going away until
there’s a brighter future for this developing
nation.
A plot to smuggle 55 million methamphetamine
tablets and more than 1.5 tons of crystal
meth disguised in beer crates was thwarted
by police in Laos, resulting in the largest
single drug seizure in Asia.
They were discovered in a truck in an area
called the “Golden Triangle”––the
meeting point of Myanmar, Laos, and Thailand,
which is notorious as a hotspot for drug production
and smuggling.
With recent unrest in Myanmar’s Shan region
and Chinese crackdown on the trade, smugglers
have looked to alternative routes––in
this case, without much success.
In another superlative, Pacific Islander Nicole
Yamase became the first citizen from The Federated
States of Micronesia to reach Challenger Deep––the
deepest part of the Mariana Trench, which
lies within the territorial waters of the
country.
Her completion of the 10-hour journey, which
took her to 36,000 feet, or 11,000 meters,
below the ocean’s surface, also makes her
only the third woman, and at 29, the second-youngest,
to ever do it.
She's a PhD student studying climate change’s
effects on microalgae, and going to the world’s
most remote places for research is all in
a days’ work for her.
On the topic of climate change, in an effort
to reduce its dependence on fossil fuels,
Sao Tome and Principe made an innovative announcement
involving deepwater platforms—but not the
oil kind.
Instead, they’re engaging in a public-private
partnership to debut Ocean Thermal Energy
Conversion technology––the first commercial
endeavor of its kind.
The floating platforms use the difference
between cold deep ocean water and warm surface
temperatures to create green energy out of
the blue.
Another island nation concerned for its future
is Kiribati, where six years ago, the government
starred in its own version of “House Hunters”
and purchased some 8.5 square miles, or 22
square kilometers, of land on Fiji to make
sure its potentially displaced residents had
somewhere to go as sea levels rise.
To use that land in the meantime, Kiribati
enlisted the help of omnipresent China to
build farms that would provide fresh produce
and meat to the island nation, which currently
imports all of its food.
Some say this is another land grab by China,
while others see it as a sustainability measure
for Kiribati.
Both of these takes miss what might be the
most interesting part of this story: an actual
overseas climate refuge in the first place.
Garment workers in Bangladesh are more protected
after an agreement was signed by some 200
international fashion companies that includes
legally binding safety commitments, independent
inspections at the factories, and contributions
for safety training and factory improvements.
The accord replaces one that was created after
a devastating factory fire that killed 1,100
people in 2013 and was set to expire.
Human rights workers praised the move, which
means protections will continue into the future,
and keep Bangladesh as one of the top garment
producers in the world.
That pandemic coffee habit may be helping
boost Honduras’ economy, according to recent
economic reports.
GDP growth for 2021 was expected to be between
2% and 5%, but new projections show almost
double that, with the country’s economy
predicted to grow by almost 9%.
This is thanks to increased activity in retail
and manufacturing, and, because of supply-chain
issues, higher prices for coffee, which is
one of the country’s primary exports.
If two’s a party and three’s a crowd,
then India is taking note.
Some states, including the country’s most
populous, Uttar Pradesh, which has 240 million
people and would be the world’s fifth most
populous country by itself, introduced a China-like
two-child policy and sterilization measures
to control population growth.
Though it still has to be adopted, the proposal
would deny state benefits, subsidies, and
jobs to anyone who has more than two children,
and dangles the carrot of incentives for anyone
who gets sterilized.
Twelve states have actually adopted similar
measures, all in an effort to limit growth
in a country that’s already the second most
populous in the world.
In the early 1900s, Namibia was known as German
South West Africa, and Germany is still dealing
with its dark history there, which included
troops that killed, tortured, and forced tens
of thousands of native peoples into the desert
to starve.
This year, then-Chancellor Angela Merkel reached
a deal that will distribute $1.1 billion Euros
over 30 years to benefit aid programs in the
African country.
But, she stopped short of calling the funding
“reparations,” and instead said it was
“reconciliation” money that would help
attempt to “heal the wounds” of the past.
China continues to expand its presence around
the globe, and in Bhutan this hasn’t been
subtle.
In the past year, satellite imagery shows
that multiple new villages have sprung up
in a 60-square-mile, or 150-square kilometer,
Bhutanese area that’s been a disputed site
before, when India and China went to head
about road construction there a handful of
years ago.
Because of aligned interests when it comes
to Chinese overreach, India has supported
Bhutan’s claims to the contested territory.
Across the world, the situation in Nicaragua
right now is unequivocally bad, and it wasn’t
much better in early 2021 when President Daniel
Ortega opted to shoot for the moon, even though
the nation is mired in social and economic
misery.
That’s when he established the National
Ministry for Extraterrestrial Space Affairs,
The Moon and Other Celestial Bodies, which
people are calling a vanity project.
Its goal is to develop a space agency that
will reach the farthest points in the universe,
but it quite literally hasn’t gotten off
the ground.
When one thinks of palm oil plantations, Malaysia
and Indonesia usually come to mind.
But Guatemala’s emerging market makes it
the world’s sixth-largest producer of palm
oil, however that success, of course, comes
at a cost.
More production has led to companies grabbing
indigenous lands at an increasing rate.
In response, some of Guatemala’s indigenous
population––almost 40% of the country’s
17 million residents––are resisting by
forcefully moving back onto the land.
Native baby sea turtle numbers on the 10-island
nation of Cape Verde are booming, in a rabbit-like
way.
The good news is that nest numbers last year
were up to 200,000, which is 20 times the
estimates from 2015.
The bad news is that sea turtles’ gender
is determined by the temperature of the sand
where the eggs are laid, and, well, the globally-warmed
beach means that about 84% of baby sea turtles
hatchlings are now female, which unfortunately
still keeps the species on the endangered
list.
When it comes to finding fodder for Central
Asian geopolitical cocktail talk, here’s
a fun fact: Tajikistan’s primary export
is migrant labor.
By September 2021, more than 1.6 million Tajiks
left the country to work in Russia.
These migrant workers then send billions of
dollars in remittances back home.
In 2019, actually, this figure accounted for
more than one-quarter of Tajikistan’s GDP,
making the ex-Soviet country still very dependent
on Russia.
Anyone who invested early in Bitcoin should
head straight to El Salvador where they can
make it crypto-rain now that the country became
the first in the world to adopt the currency
as legal tender.
Though some, including major lender the International
Monetary Fund, are skeptical because of the
volatile and risky nature of cryptocurrencies,
others are optimistic, such as Salvodorians
who can dip into their Chivo wallet app and
find $30 of Bitcoin waiting for them.
In the ongoing fight against ISIS, officials
in Iraq declared a moderate victory with the
capture of the Islamic State’s finance minister,
Sami Jassem al-Ajuz.
The kicker?
He’s alive.
The arrest could provide Iraq and international
allies with a treasure trove of intelligence
about the terrorist organization that, although
has retreated from daily headlines in recent
years, maintains quite active in sleeper cells
throughout the Middle East.
Two residents in Guyana are not staying quiet
about protecting the planet, something they
argue is a fundamental right to humanity’s
sustainability.
The pair is suing their country for having
approved oil exploration licenses, saying
it violates the government’s legal duty
to protect the right of future generations
to a healthy environment.
This David-versus-Goliath fight pits them
against ExxonMobil, which is eyeing a potential
8 billion gallons of oil in offshore drilling,
which would make it the company’s largest
extraction site in the world.
There’s nothing like the discovery of 1.3
million-year-old stone tools to make this
point in time seem, well, short.
Archeologists in Morocco recently discovered
the artifacts in a site associated with human
ancestor homo erectus, almost doubling the
previous start date for the dawn of the stone-tool
era in north Africa.
What’s mind-boggling is that these tools
aren’t even close to the oldest traces of
human ancestors, which date all the way back
to more than 4 million years ago.
In Kyrgyzstan, Central Asia’s only democracy,
just over one-third of the population turned
out in a snap election that put populist politician
and convicted kidnapper Sadyr Japarov into
power.
The former Soviet country sits between China,
which has invested in its infrastructure,
and Russia, to which it still has significant
loyalties, including from its newly elected
president who has vowed to remain allied with
both neighbors—something that will be tough
to balance amid his own country’s partially
self-inflicted political turmoil.
There’s some positive news about elephants
coming out of Gabon, where new research shows
the population of forest elephants—a cousin
to the savanna-dwelling pachyderms—seem
to be doing better than expected.
Previous estimates reported there were about
50,000 left in the Central African country,
but a recent study shows that number to be
closer to 95,000, thanks to strict anti-poaching
regulations and land conservation measures.
Athleisure-wearing, latte-drinking urbanites
might need an extra downward dog and shot
of espresso to deal with their supply-chain
woes this year—especially with products
like Lululemon and coffee coming from Vietnam,
where a combination of lockdowns and factory
conditions has prompted millions of workers
to leave cities and return to their countryside
homes.
Manufacturers are having a tough time luring
them back, and that was bad news for a supply
chain already in crisis.
An Arizona man who conducted a years-long
human trafficking ring selling babies from
the Marshall Island to American parents was
sentenced to six years in prison and forced
to pay hundreds of thousands in restitution
charges.
The man would pay around $10,000 for pregnant
Marshallese women to come to the United States
and then arrange for their newborns to be
adopted by couples for $40,000.
Officials estimate some 70 adoptions took
place this way, taking advantage of the “compact
of free association,” which allowed them
to travel or move to the US without restriction.
On the subject of pregnancy, Polish researchers
discovered a first: an Egyptian mummy with
child.
Originally they thought the mummy mommy was
a male priest, but further investigation uncovered
a small femur bone thought to belong to a
fetus about 25 to 30 weeks old.
Scientists called the find unique, and important
to Egyptology, in which little research has
been done on females.
In not-so-sweet news, Ben & Jerry’s announced
it would stop selling its ice cream in occupied
Palestinian territories, making a very public
corporate statement against the Israeli settlements
there, which are not recognized by international
law.
Israeli officials called the decision a “capitulation
to antisemitism.”
The brand, however, will still be available
throughout the internationally recognized
territory of Israel, which sort of makes this
ban “half-baked.”
It’s banned for poachers to remove succulents
from the desert in South Africa, but that
hasn’t stopped it from being an explosive
problem in a country that’s home to one-third
of the world’s succulent species.
Specifically, people are harvesting Conophytum,
which is a genus of flowering plants that
consists of over 100 species, many of which
are on the endangered list.
They’re then sold to hot markets including
Korea and China, where the plants that were
once considered low-class have become popular
for being low-maintenance.
Across the pond, Venezuelans have been fleeing
their country in one of the world’s largest
human migrations, and one-third of them head
to neighboring Colombia.
Recently, Colombia announced its decision
to provide temporary legal status to more
than 1.7 million migrants who had fled there
in recent years.
That means the migrants can work legally for
up to 10 years.
A collapsed economy has created a humanitarian
crisis, and refugees in search of a better
life may find that with Colombia’s legal
acceptance of them.
Last year the president of Turkmenistan erected
a gilded statue of a beloved breed of dog,
the Alabai.
This year, he took it a step further and announced
a national holiday honoring the large, shepherd-like
canine.
The paw-liday included a contest for the country’s
best dog and a medal given to its top border
guard dog.
Alabai now shares the special day with another
of Turkmenistan’s celebrated: the Akhal-Teke
horse breed.
Both are considered important parts of the
national heritage, where herding is a traditional
pastime.
Traditionally, the transfer of power is supposed
to be peaceful and seamless.
In Samoa, it wasn’t.
Fiame Naomi Mata’afa finally became the
country’s prime minister in July, following
several months of constitutional crisis during
which her predecessor, Tuilaepa Sailele Malielegaoi,
refused to acknowledge her victory.
The former leader had led the country for
more than two decades, and would not step
down.
After a series of legal battles and appeals,
Mata’afa finally assumed control and is
making history doing it as Samoa’s first
female prime minister.
In Belize, officials are both making and saving
history–ecologically, that is.
This year a coalition of conservation organizations
banded together to save one of the world’s
last pristine rainforests, preserving 367
square miles, or 950 square kilometers of
land from deforestation.
This area is part of the larger, which crosses
Mexico, Belize, and Guatemala, and means a
biodiversity hotspot roughly the size of Florida
will be saved in perpetuity.
Something that’s not going to last forever
is Filipino President Rodrigo Duterte, who
is constitutionally barred from seeking another
six-year term.
Ahead of the May elections, those looking
to replace him include a potpourri of people,
including his daughter Sara Duterte; son and
namesake of the country’s former dictator,
Ferdinand “Bongbong” Marcos; former actor
and Manila mayor Francisco Domagoso; and newly
retired boxing star Manny Pacquiao.
With candidates expected to perform onstage
with the public judging them on their singing
and dancing abilities, the pool is certainly
high on the entertainment factor.
To the south, the Indonesian island of Biak
is becoming an unexpected player in Elon Musk’s
world.
That’s because Indonesian president Joko
Widodo, as part of his goal to modernize the
nation, personally pitched the tech giant
on launching spacecraft from the island that
sits 70 miles or 110 kilometers, south of
the Equator.
Facing displacement, the indigenous population
isn’t supportive of the proposal.
Musk has also stayed mum on the issue, but
we all know his penchant for explosive announcements.
Atmospheric conditions also made headlines
in Bolivia, where UV radiation levels in La
Paz hit 21, and that’s on a scale that typically
tops out at 20.
The Bolivian capital sits at 11,800 feet,
or 3,600 meters, above sea level, and low
levels of clouds caused by climate change
combined with a heat wave skyrocketed numbers
on the UV index.
The World Health Organization calls an index
of 11 “extreme," and 10 minutes exposed
at these levels starts to burn the skin.
At 21, people just stay inside.
More than doubling the age of most of her
competitors, a 46-year-old gymnast representing
Uzbekistan took her final bow at the Olympics
in Tokyo this summer.
It was Oksana Chusovitina’s eighth Olympics;
she won the silver medal for vault in 2008,
and capped off with 11 medals won at 17 world
championships.
Up next?
Spending more time with her Olympic wrestling
husband and her son, who at 22, is older than
most Olympic gymnasts.
In Libya, there’s some frightening news
on the artificial intelligence front.
A report commissioned by the United Nations
found that a military drone strike used in
the country’s civil war may have been carried
out autonomously.
Allegedly, militia fighters were hunted down
and attacked by a “weapons system” that
did not require data connectivity.
Though it’s implied, the report doesn’t
go as far as to say the drone acted autonomously.
Vagueness here is de rigueur, as the report
also doesn’t say whether anyone was injured
or killed.
The island-nation of Tonga managed to largely
avoid the global pandemic, but it’s dealing
with its own epidemic now, as methamphetamine
use has become pervasive and very problematic
in the country of 100,000.
It’s so bad that the king made a plea to
Tongan parliament asking for help with the
crisis, which is accounting for 60% of admissions
to Tonga’s mental health wards and filling
up local prisons.
Tonga has long been a stop on the drug route
from Asia to New Zealand and Australia—this
just means that the drugs are increasingly
stopping instead of passing through.
Something else that’s stopping is the Parana
River.
South America’s second-largest river straddles
Paraguay, Argentina, and Brazil, and sadly,
it’s the lowest it’s been in more than
70 years.
Scientists say deforestation in the Amazon
is to blame, as rainfall, much of which emanates
from the forest itself, has significantly
decreased.
As a result, the river is 10.5 feet or 3 meters
lower than normal, and threatening the lives
and businesses of people who populate more
than 60 towns along its shores.
Also threatening was two mens’ plot to unseat
Jordan’s King Abdullah, a crime for which
they were sentenced to 15 years in prison.
They were aides to the king’s half-brother,
who was removed from the line of succession
in 2004.
But not to be deterred, his plan using these
proxies included rallying civilian support
to oust Abdullah.
The twist?
Some say all three may have been unknowingly
backed by the Trump administration, who saw
Abdullah as an obstacle in securing an Israeli-Palestinian
peace treaty.
The king, however, will remain in power and
these two will go to jail.
When an immigrant commits a crime in the United
Kingdom, they get deported, often by airplane.
Lately, however, the loads have been light
with just four people sent back to Jamaica
on a recent 350-passenger Airbus A350-900
flight.
That evens out to about $66,000, or 50,000
pounds, per person.
These costs have people wondering about the
viability of such an expensive program, while
others say it’s critical to get convicted
criminals out of the country.
Finds that will happily be sent overseas include
two of the world’s largest diamonds, unearthed
this year in Botswana.
A 1,174-carat and 1,098-carat diamond were
both discovered weeks apart in the country’s
mines, which are some of the top-producing
in the world.
Each diamond is about the size of someone’s
hand, and they come at an important time for
the market which is trying to rebound after
the pandemic—bright news for the country
and the soon-to-be betrothed.
Another unearthing took place in Mongolia,
where archeologists were able to use a new
technology to look below ground and map the
ancient city of Karakorum, the capital of
the Mongolian Empire established by Genghis
Kahn in the 1200s.
Using magnetic fields to determine the footprint’s
layout and structural composition, the researchers
determined, among other things, that the city
was only at about 40% capacity, likely home
to laborers and craftspeople, while the majority
lived a more nomadic lifestyle.
And that brings us to halfway.
We’ll plow through the remaining 98 entries
on Friday when part two is released, but you
don’t have to wait until then, or sit through
ads for that matter, if you sign up for Nebula
today.
The streaming platform was made by creators
like me and my friends from Real Science,
Medlife Crisis, Real Life Lore, and more.
We all wanted to focus on content, and not
stress about demonetization and algorithms,
so we made our own streaming site.
On Nebula, you can watch dozens of your favorite
educational creators’ normal videos early
and ad-free, occasional extended cuts and
companion videos, and big-budget Nebula Originals.
Of course, we still want you all to be able
to watch our stuff easily, so we’re partnering
with CuriosityStream, which has thousands
of nonfiction shows and documentaries streaming
at your fingertips and is a big fan of what
we do at Nebula.
So when you sign up for CuriosityStream at
CuriosityStream.com/Wendover, you get Nebula
included for free.
Even better news is that CuriosityStream is
offering 26% off its annual plan, and you
benefit: CuriosityStream plus Nebula all for
less than $15 a year.
I think we all need some good news after some
of the stories in the year-end round-up, so
how about you try watching CuriosityStream’s
original documentary about how the groundbreaking,
newly-launched James Webb Telescope was designed
and built.
So, to get your time and money’s worth,
sign up for the bundle deal by clicking the
button on screen or heading to CuriosityStream.com/Wendover,
and you’ll be helping support independent
creators while you’re at it.